this event is just under an hour
just working yeah that works
i am bruce dobby i am the former editor
and publisher of the nashville scene
which is a
local alternative news weekly before
then i was a
political writer at the nashville banner
and
now i am resurrecting the old nashville
banner
where i am the editor and publisher we
currently have a few stories up at
thenashvillebanner.com
so
it is my distinct honor today to
introduce curtis wilkie
by way of introduction um
just let me say i uh one of the most
influential books
i read as a
young
lad growing up in southern louisiana was
this book which was the boys on the bus
i've never really known how timothy
crouse or cruz krauss
pronounces his last name and so much to
my um
this book at the time i couldn't decide
whether i was bob woodward or hunter s
thompson and uh
envisioning myself to be the mutant love
child of them
i set off and embarked on a career in
journalism but absolutely loved this
book and this book in itself was a form
of new journalism
um at the time
as part of that new journalism it took
an introspective look at the craft
itself in a way that was part gonzo and
part long-form uh literary non-fiction
it was just just a fabulous book
it's so meaningful for and this book in
large measure inspired me to want to be
a political reporter
um so it's really a great honor to
introduce curtis in large measure
because while timothy
krauss largely pillories
the pack mentality of reporters who were
on the bus in 1972 covering the
presidential campaign
this man emerges as a journalistic hero
krause writes
about sitting down next to a 30ish
dark-haired reporter wearing a palm
beach suit and a drooping mustache who
looked too hung over to object to my
presence
after a long silence he spoke up in a
twangy southern accent and introduced
himself as curtis wilkie he was from
mississippi and had been senior at ole
miss in 1964 when general walker led his
famous charge on the administ on the
administration building
he then goes on to mention his career
beginning as a reporter in clarksdale
mississippi at the register and of
course at the time he was working for a
daily in wilmington delaware that was
owned by a conservative republican paper
he says
about wilkie
about his efforts to report uniquely on
the campaign trail and not
report what the pac was reporting
nothing seemed to deter him nothing
drove him from the safety of the to the
back to the safety of the pack
wilkie continued to trust his own
judgment and write about whatever he
himself thought was important in october
when he was one of the few reporters to
file a full account of the nixon rally
where the president smiled at the site
of demonstrators being beaten up the
paper printed his articles without
questioning them
so
long time it covered eight presidential
campaigns i believe 26 years at the
boston globe his new book out as an
anthology of many of the stories he
wrote at the globe and elsewhere
would you please welcome curtis wilkie
[Applause]
thank you all for being here
it's always nice to be back
always nice to be in nashville and i'm
honored again to
be invited back to the southern festival
of books um
this is a collection of uh my stories
drawn over a period of more than 40
years
i am a southerner i was a
senior at ole miss
when james merritt
integrated the school if those of you
who were at the earlier session you
heard some talk about my alma mater
i assure you we're much better than we
were
then
um
as a young reporter
my first job was in clarksdale
mississippi for a small daily
to clarksdale press register and
as a result i was fortunate enough to
cover the civil rights movement uh
almost daily and i covered other things
too i can assure you everything from
civic clubs to old bits to
raffle
whatever
but the civil rights story was
the big story in the mississippi delta
and it was the biggest story in the
country so i was extremely fortunate
to uh to be there then and it really
became a frame of reference for me for
the rest of my life
clarksdale was the home of a wonderful
man named aaron henry who was the state
president of naacp and
aaron
not only became a great source for me
but a great friend
he made sure as a young reporter that i
was able to
meet all the people in the movement who
were coming through the delta
i got to meet jackie robinson which was
a great thrill and it was so much fun to
tell him that as a little leaguer i had
used the jackie robinson bat i still
remember it had a had a thick handle
um
everybody who came through everybody
from
uh stokely carmichael to dr king
and it was an experience it was
fascinating there are several stories
about the movement
in the book
i teach writing at ole miss now and
among the things i tell my students is
that
quotes really help make stories you know
you can
think you're a wonderful writer but you
know if you don't have good anecdotes
and quotes and
good description and good stories to
write about
you're going to be spinning your wheels
and i'm going to start off basically
with not something i wrote but
quotes
the first one uh involved a visit that
dr king made to the delta
in the spring of 68.
it turned out it was the last days of
his life and he was there trying to
rally support for the poor people's
campaign
and imagine that here's a man who is a
nobel prize winner
the major figure in the movement
and i was the only reporter covering him
for a couple of days traveling around
the delta dr king was with jose williams
and ralph abernathy
and they drove around in a
big sedan i followed behind them in my
little volkswagen beetle
uh one of the events was at a black
church in marx mississippi
and uh at that event i was the only
other white guy there there was a
photographer for the associated press
named jack thornell who had won the
pulitzer year before for a famous
picture of james meredith when he was
ambushed
and shot on the highway in mississippi
and he spread eagles
and uh jack won the pulitzer for that so
we're there covering uh dr king and
suddenly
a white guy comes bursting into the
church
and he's reaching in his back pocket and
there for a split second
i had a camera and a notebook
and i'm wondering
do i try to disarm this guy
or do i get my camera ready and take the
next pulitzer prize-winning picture well
happily uh he didn't pull a gun he
pulled a hundred dollar bill
and took it up to dr king
interrupted the program dr king was
uh amazed he was looking at the hundred
dollar bill and then he says
well uh uh what's your name he
determined the man's name was money
mobley he said well god bless you
brother bob lee anybody who gives a
hundred dollars to the movement can say
a few words
well that was a big mistake because
money bobbly had had a few drinks by
this time and he started in on the
kennedys
and and also he was denying that anybody
was hungry in the south or that we had
poverty
and uh he became so obstructed that
uh josie williams and ralph abernethy
had to sort of frog marching out of the
church and created quite a commotion
afterwards
dr king is out in the car and
he's
eating lunch and i'm talking to him and
i said
dr king were you frightened back there
and here's what he told me
no i'm not frightened
i move without fear because i know i'm
right
i'd be immobilized if i were afraid
besides the climate of violence is
gradually decreasing in the south
and two weeks later he was dead
the book is has a strange name assassins
eccentrics politicians and other persons
of interest and
one of my friends called says you know
who are the assassins other than say an
obvious one delayed beckwith um
who i
wrote about
and i added up and they're probably
five or six assassins or
they're either identifiable or anonymous
in the middle east during the years i
lived there
and there are other people who were
victims of assassination um
i only met medgar evers once that was
the first year i worked
in clarksdale and um
he was killed within three or four
months of
becoming a reporter
and of course dr king uh robert kennedy
came through the delta and i got to
cover that um
so um we had more than our share of
assassins
in the south at that time
uh fast forward to
1994.
uh by this time i have conned the globe
into letting me live and work out of new
orleans i got tired of freezing to death
in boston
and so they did and one of the first
stories i was able to cover
was the third trial of
byron delaybeck with
the assassin of medgar evers there had
been two
earlier trials in the 60s and it
resulted in a hung jury but they were
able to
get new evidence and they brought him
back to
trial uh 30 years later
and
a set up piece
that i wanted to do
before the trial began i was able to get
beckwith's phone number he was living by
this time in signal mountain tennessee
and uh
damned if i didn't get him on the phone
and i could hear his wife in the
background yelling at him delay don't
you talk to that man well he talked to
me and uh some pretty
amazing quotes uh not all of them well i
read some of them are you know too ugly
to um to be spoken publicly
but uh i'll give you a couple i think
really reveal the character of this
assassin
he began talking
after he had finished with the blacks
about the babylonian talmudist
and i said excuse me he said the tau
muteus boy don't you know what i'm
talking about i said well i think i just
figured it out
and he went on
babylonian talmudis
are a set of dogs
if you'll read in the king james version
of the bible a dog is a male [ __ ]
and god says kill them
says racial mixing is a capital crime
like murder is a capital crime
but the bible doesn't say thou shalt not
cure
it says thou shalt do no murder
and he was looking forward to his trial
which was coming up in a couple of weeks
and he kind of concluded my interview by
saying
i'm full of enthusiasm and adventure
i'm proud of my enemies they're every
color but white every creed but
christian
so i had the joy of
covering the trial
set for most the time with willie morris
my dear friend
and
the verdict came in on a saturday
morning and
this was my
lead a mississippi jury of eight blacks
and four whites reached across a painful
gulf of time and turmoil yesterday
to convict byron delay beckwith of the
1963 murder of civil rights leader
medgar evers
when the verdict was announced at 10 35
on the second day of deliberation
there was a burst of cheers from a
pocket of spectators surrounding the
widow merly evers within seconds as word
that beckwith had been found guilty
passed from the courtroom cheering
echoed through the halls of the hinds
county courthouse where others were
standing vigil so
generally reporters try to be
objective and unemotional but
this was you know one time that i was
glad i was there and glad to
see that old buzzard uh
go off and he did die in prison
there was yet another case involving an
old civil rights murder
it was the fire bombing death of
the
forest county president of naacp
vernon damer at his home near
hattiesburg in 1966
and
as they did with beckwith there was a
another
renewed prosecution
and
there seemed to be momentum toward
bringing
to trial a man named sam bowers who
was the imperial wizard of the white
knights of the ku klux klan he was the
guy
who had
orchestrated the murders in neshoba
county and had called for the murder of
vernon damer another truly evil man
they were not sure whether they were
going to put together a good enough case
and
i was in new orleans and i got a call
from a friend of mine jerry himmelstein
he was the head of the anti-defamation
league in new orleans and he said can
you come see me i got something i want
to talk about
he told me that there was a fellow in
mississippi that he had been involved
with
who was prepared to testify
against bowers and
this fellow was afraid that his
potential testimony was being discounted
by the prosecutors that he had heard
important
details and
he wanted to go public with it he was
willing to talk to a reporter
and jerry said uh is that something you
would be interested in i said my god you
know when can we go and we went the next
day over to the mississippi gulf coast
where i interviewed a
fellow named bob stringer
it led to interviews i had with members
of the damer family and and other people
and this is the way i begin
um
my story that was several weeks before
the actual trial
for for three decades bob stringer has
lived with the memory of a conversation
he overheard in the back booths of
john's cafe
a hopper's hangout of the ku klux klan
in laurel mississippi
it was the winner of 1966 and sam bowers
a jukebox operator who moonlighted as
imperial wizard of the white knights of
the ku klux klan was voicing his
frustration that clan elements in
neighboring forest county had been
unable to suppress the voting
registration efforts of the local naacp
leader werner damer senior
stringer in an interview recalled the
exchange the other day
quote
sam said
something's got to be done about that
damer down south and he slapped the
counter
then henry the boxer said
we need to put a code four on him
in the parliaments of the clan
colt 4 called for death
and within hours damer was dead
well they did bring sam bowers to trial
i covered his trial and
you know it was fun to sit with old
friends uh
your own will campbell like will
campbell uh uh came in and
uh i was sitting with will uh near the
end of this trial
and this is the way that one wound up
this was in 1998.
sam bowers in an imperial wizard of the
white knights of the ku klux klan and
reputedly the mastermind began behind
the campaign of terror across
mississippi three decades ago
was convicted yesterday for a 1966
civil rights murder after three previous
prosecutions had failed so again
that was a great and dramatic moment
there just uh interestingly uh those of
you who might know i might have known
well or knew of him uh he was not only a
great civil rights champion
from south mississippi
but also tried to minister to the klan
he said you know they're all children of
god and he knew sam bowers
and uh when he came to the courthouse
he not only had a very warm and
emotional meeting with members of the
damer family but
he went over and he hugged sam bowers
and
when the verdict was announced
there was cheering in the courtroom
again
and i looked over at will and will had a
tear and it was basically ready to cry i
said well
you may be the only person in this
courtroom who's sorry to see
sam bowers convicted he said
jesus never liked to see any man in
chains so you know will's is just an
extraordinary guy and you all were lucky
to have him up in
these parts um he was a dear dear man
well i think i've disposed of the
assassins i'll
move on to eccentrics um
the last time i was here was the day
jimmy carter won the nobel prize i
remember
everybody seemed happy about it i i
covered jimmy carter i covered the
uh i covered him for a year when he was
running for president
uh i was the i was a
young reporter i was a token southerner
at the boston globe and
had no seniority and when they began
making assignments in late
1975
to cover different candidates said okay
kid you get the peanut farmer from
georgia
well
carter and i had a fairly checkered
relationship through that whole campaign
he thought i was a smart aleck and
he was probably right and uh and i think
he was resentful of me and two or three
other southern reporters he felt we were
pressing him too hard to be
too liberal more liberal than he was
comfortable for all the admirable things
he's done there were some
things he was not able not willing to do
um i became a really good friend with
his younger brother billy carter and i
see enough people around my age out
there that you'll remember billy and uh
billy was was a wonderful guy and
ran the service station uh
and it was a classic good old boy
situation
and i would
go hang out with billy and the boys and
drink beer
with him i would go over there and drink
beer with billy on sunday morning back
in those days you couldn't sell beer on
sunday in georgia so billy gave it away
to his friends
and miss legion
uh jimmy carter's mother
used to give me a hard time because i
never went to sunday school like the
other reporters that would go to billy
and we'd sit around drink beer well
jimmy carter got elected we're all
spending three months in southwest
georgia while he's preparing his
government and it was enlivened
that winner by
billy carter's candidacy for mayor of
plains
so you know wasn't much of a campaign
but was kind of fun
uh
billy carter's first official act if he
is elected mayor of plains today
will be to cut down an artificial
christmas tree just erected on public
land across the highway from his service
station
in fact the brother of the
president-elect said saturday morning a
can of beer in hand
me and the boys were thinking about
getting together tonight and chopping
the goddamn thing down then
he looked scornfully at the tree a thin
towering green plastic monstrosity which
was shimmering in the late autumn sun
it was donated to the town
and is a symbol of all the things billy
carter thinks are wrong with planes
these days
well sorry to say billy did not get
elected but
that night vigilantes did lassoed the
tree and
dragged it down the highway and uh they
never could find out who did it billy
conveniently had an alibi uh
the sad footnote to that is billy did
overdo it sometimes i felt guilty that i
was one of the reporters who
did stories that were kind of glorifying
billy's outrageous behavior and it kind
of he
he became more and more
outrageous and so
some two years later i had to go back to
plains to do this story
for more than two years he was on stage
the merchant of foolishness in his
theater of the absurd
he gave outrageous quotes to reporters
for free publicity
and peddled outlandish behavior to
promoters to promoters for as much as
five thousand dollars of performance
for a while excess was success for the
president's brother billy carter
but recently his string began to play
out and last tuesday night he was
admitted to the alcoholic rehabilitation
center at long beach naval hospital in
california to begin a stern regiment
that will last six to eight weeks
back home in plains his friends and
members of his family hope the treatment
will restore billy garter for in recent
weeks he has been beset by many problems
his health has deteriorated and he has
become a public embarrassment
well
billy did finally
recover uh but he
suffered from pancreatic cancer and
eventually died incidentally that
illness claimed every member of jimmy
carter's family but
the president himself claimed his
brother and all his siblings
it's i covered all of the carter white
house
as a result of having covered his
campaign and
um
i was there for the last day of his
campaign in 1980 and it wound up
having
more drama than we expected if you
recall at that point
the hostages were being held in iran we
were thinking at any minute they were
going to be freed
we set out that last day of the campaign
monday before the election
and we i think we went to philadelphia
to los angeles portland seattle and flew
back to
georgia all in
one day
and uh
on our way back to georgia one of
carter's uh
aides
was on the press plane and he came back
and talked to him he was a pretty good
friend
and he said when are you going to write
i said well i can't write anything again
until uh this afternoon election day he
said well i can
tell you
we're going to get clobbered
they thought we all thought it was going
to be close
and they had a poll that they had just
gotten that showed that all of
everything they were hoping for had
collapsed overnight and they were only
going to win about five or six
states
so
i was privy to this information but i
couldn't
um
tell anyone about it and i had and i was
pulled that morning when carter voted
and i was going to be with the president
and i knew that he knew he was going to
lose
but i couldn't say anything and he
didn't know that i knew
so it's an extraordinary situation but
gave me a certain insight
into the story that i wrote
and this is the way i began
after a final punishing campaign journey
of more than six thousand miles
president jimmy carter made a melancholy
return to his hometown yesterday he
struggled to keep from crying as he told
his followers of the difficult and
politically costly decisions that he
felt were costing him his presidency
even though the polls had just opened he
appeared exhausted and disheartened by
the grim word from his staff
based on their own polling data that the
election appeared to be irretrievably
lost
carter had learned the worst a few hours
before on the long overnight flight from
seattle to georgia
news his aides had kept from him until
he could complete in a confident and
fighting manner the last of seven stops
on both sides of the continent that they
had scheduled for him on the final day
of his campaign
he had not known of it in seattle where
he rallied a late night thrown in a
cavernous airport hangar and blew kisses
at a young heckler who held a sign that
said
carter blew his four years of time
he had not even lost his compulsion as
another man bearing a sign that read
carter's maternal grandmother is a
mulatto
attempted to storm the stage and had to
be dragged away
as the hour approached midnight on the
pacific coast it was nearly 3 a.m
back home and 17 hours since he had
first set out
carter delivered one of his finest
speeches of the campaign
but outside the hangar his longtime
associate and press secretary jody
powell
stood despondent on the airport tarmac
washed by a gentle autumn rain
powell had heard of patrick cadell's
latest poll findings over sophisticated
communication system aboard air force
one
the information showed that carter had
slipped further behind in the target
states and as the president basked in
the chairs of the crowd
powell turned to another carter aide and
said simply
it's gone
and carter himself was told before his
plane descended it dawn yesterday to the
feneria southwest georgia landscape that
was shrouded in a heavy
ground fog
the leaves are dull and dying brown in
the pecan groves and little calves
awaiting slaughter for veal tethered in
a field outside plains
well uh
i also covered bill clinton
covered bill clinton for about a year i
remember the first time
i met bill clinton was in 78
he had just been elected governor and he
was at a big democratic convention in
memphis
and were half a dozen i was standing
around somebody introduced me to
a guy named clinton it didn't register
and he says
he just got elected uh
governor of arkansas i looked and said
he looks like a boy scout i mean he was
so young so i had known clinton a little
bit from that time um
and uh
in early in 92 when he became a formal
candidate i was traveling with him in
new hampshire and it
occurred to me
as
later in the year as he was about to get
the democratic nomination in new york
that
i needed to reconstruct that month in
new hampshire where
he went through
so many
adverse situations it would have sunk
any other candidate it started off with
uh what betsy wright one of his aides
called the bimbo eruptions there was a
charge it
had used state money to finance five
different liaisons with five different
women then you had the infamous jennifer
flowers
confessions and then he had the
the
draft dodging letter that was leaked
where he had
written to an rotc guy thanking him for
saving uh saving me bill clinton from
the draft and
you know
gary hart got sunk four years before for
nothing like this and it just showed
this guy's resilience that he was
unwilling to quit
so i reconstructed
the
33 days that he spent in new hampshire
for a magazine piece that appeared
later it was the
first time i ever did a story in third
person narrative writing it like it's a
novel with no attribution i wrote it
like i was god and i had overheard
everything seen everything i'd seen a
lot because i traveled with him but um
it helped
bill and hillary both had talked to me
at linkedin and all of his aides had
talked to me so i was able to put
together a pretty good i think
account of all this inside baseball that
went on this very dramatic period
and um
this is the way i begin the uh the story
bill clinton's time was expiring in new
hampshire
worn down by illness his voice frayed by
fatigue his jogger's body swollen from
the consumption of junk food he seemed
to be fighting a losing battle
a freezing rain cast a treacherous glaze
on the highway as he was driven to
nashua less than 60 hours before the
polls open
still clinton was encouraged when he
arrived at the event and saw that an
overflow crowd had come to hear him on
the saturday night before the premier
this was a good sign he told his wife
hillary clinton was not so sanguine
how do we know she said that they're not
just coming to see the freak show
just a couple more um
i
lived in jerusalem for four years and it
covered the middle east i was actually
there off and on over about a
10-year period and
at one point
i went and spent about a week in gaza
which has been very much in the news
lately when i was there
the situation in gaza was a bit
different it was still under israeli
occupation
it was as it is today
disgracefully
poor
sad and
at that time forgotten and i felt that i
needed to
go do a magazine piece about
gaza
this was a piece that appeared
in the boston globe magazine in 1986.
welcome
the characters in arabic english and
obligatory hebrew crow and falsely
bright colors
as sad as toys in the children's cancer
ward
across an arch over the gateway to the
city
welcome to gaza
welcome to a 25-mile stretch of almost
unrelieved squalor
where raw sewage runs openly in the
alleys of the palestinian refugee camps
and flows like a polluted tidal stream
into the mediterranean
welcome to a teeming territory that is
served for nearly 40 years his home for
thousands of refugees who long ago lost
hope
largely abandoned by the arab brothers
and ignored by the western world they
are ruled by israel's army of occupation
and economically bled each day by
measures imposed by the israeli
government
welcome to another of the great shames
of 20th century civilization
this latest dwelling place of the
wretched of the earth
as revolutionary writer friends fanon
once described another group of
downtrodden arabs living under
colonization in north africa
there is however no revolution brewing
here
none of the palpable anger seething into
palestinian west bank cities of hebron
and nablus
the people of gaza have been beaten by
circumstance into submission
well i was wrong
i wrote that that appeared in september
of 1986 the first rocks of the first
intifada the palestinian revolution were
thrown in gaza
in uh november of
1987 so i misread the uh incipient
revolutionary spirit that existed in
gaza and of course
things have changed israel gave it gave
up on it they didn't want it
egypt which had controlled gaza before
the 67 war they don't want it back
nobody wants gaza it continues to be
a very very
sad uh hellhole
but at least it's uh no longer forgotten
um the last piece i was going to do
uh
bruce you mentioned hunter thompson uh
uh
you guys remember hunter thompson thank
you a few people do uh
when i first started teaching at ole
miss he was a co-figure on campuses
and uh hunter killed himself about eight
or nine years ago and i still use some
of hunter's writing just to try to
encourage my
students not to emulate him but
to to you know to be kind of be dare to
be different in your writing
um
hunter was a friend of mine we got to
know each other in the 72 campaign uh
we're covering george mcgovern
and i had known him uh
ever since
that time uh
i had gotten back from the middle east
in 88 was in boston
and i was in a cab and the cab driver
said uh
uh
whatever happened to that guy hunter
thompson he knew i was a reporter he
said
i read somewhere he was he turned 50 the
other day and i thought my god you know
i can't imagine
hunter thompson
50 of course i was 48 at the time but uh
you know hunter was kind of like peter
pan he's never supposed to get old
so i tried to locate hunter out in aspen
and i left several
calls at a number i had for him i left
to call it
the
woody creek tavern where he spent much
of his time and
finally several days later i got a
collect call from dr thompson uh
and so anyway he says come on out we'll
have a great time you'll get to
see some friends one of my former
roommates at ole miss was one of his
running mates out and
aspen and uh actually uh
uh i'm now married to that guy's uh
first cousin so uh
kind of fun mississippi is
so weird you know what
in mississippi you don't dare tell a lot
of stories with people's names because
invariably somebody's going to be
related to them
i never forget i was called upon a few
years ago to do a speech at
the mississippi economic council big
meeting on election year all the
statewide candidates were there and i
was telling old tales of
these baroque politicians from the 60s
and ross barnett and
all these characters it was one
particularly
uh uh objectionable guy named jimmy
swann who was a clan candidate in
in
1967 he got a hundred thousand votes
which is pretty sobering
and so i told several swan stories about
he said that you know mississippi must
not sacrifice itself upon the ugly altar
of immigration et cetera et cetera and i
sat down feeling very happy people had
laughed and clapped and the emcee looked
over at me and said that's very good mr
wilkie we enjoyed that i just need to
tell you i'm jimmy swann's son so
but anyway i digress i'll go read you
the lead for the peace i did on hunter i
had a great time with him he kept me up
all night for uh
two nights hunter uh was like a bat he
uh
slept all day to get up about six and
have breakfast and he would drink and
do all sorts of other things uh
uh through the night and um i went out
to his cabin and we sat around and
talked and i would try to keep up with
him with the emulsion beer every now and
then and i don't know how the guy did it
but um
i wound up
trying to do the magazine piece uh in a
parody of hunter's style and that's
impossible but i tried and had a little
bit of fun and
uh if i tried this on my students today
they would know what i'm talking about
maybe some of this
you will get this is a piece that
appeared in the boston globe
magazine in 1988 so reagan was still
in power then and
this is the way i began
so many of the icons of our generation
are in ruins victims of time and
reagan's cultural revolution
just say no of the new catchwords and
the red queen and white rabbit have been
replaced by king condom
john lennon is seven years dead and
timothy leary might as well be
jerry rubin promotes capitalism janice
and jimmy dwayne allman and jim morrison
are gone
otis redding and mama cass
gone
all gone
james brown's screams have lost their
pitch
leonard skinner's free bird crashed in a
swamp
richard brought again snuffed himself
the landscape is littered with
burned-out cases
children of the 1950s who spent
themselves over the next two decades
like roman candles
but there is a survivor unrepentant and
unforgiving
lurking in a log cabin high in the
colorado rockies
hunter s thompson just reached the
landmark age of 50
and after a midlife low when it was
feared he was finished
the outlaw prince of gonzo journalism is
writing again
with the fury of a shark and a feeding
frenzy
so
those are all i have every time i do
something like this my wife tells me
you've gone on too long so uh i tried to
spare you some
long long
uh
reading but try to hit some highlights
tell some stories uh
we've got a couple of minutes if anybody
has a question i'll be happy to
try to try to deal with something in the
time remaining
curtis wilkie those are just fabulous
stories uh fabulous we'd like to let's
open it up for questions um
one quick observation that quote where
you have the simile like roman candles
do you remember the passage from jack
kerouac when he oh burn burn burn burn
burn
sure
you know uh on the road was yeah very
influential
to me i was a student at ole miss and
i actually quit school uh for a semester
and went on the road because of that
damn book and
the uh the only and unfortunately i
wrote two short stories that made their
way into publication they were both
awful
and i've burned any copy i've ever
encountered and knew that i didn't have
a future
in fiction
but um you know the kerouac and also the
fact that i did flunk uh
uh feature writing which is the course i
now teach today
uh encouraged me to drop out for a
semester and and it was very fortunate
because
i was back in ole miss i should have
already graduated i was back there for
all the excitement in the fall of 62
when james merritt
was finally admitted with the help of
about 30 000 troops
truly extraordinary uh experience
but sure i remember uh burn burn burn
yeah hey we're going to go to him for
this i want to get out one quick
question um
the uh north towards home then the
willie morrisses who went went
up east we had a number of reporters
come through this market um
halberstam um i mean the list goes on
and on um
who southerners who ended up being quite
successful on the east coast in in
mainstream media environments up there
what accounted for that
well i think so many of us felt driven
to get out of there in the 60s because
it had been so bad so intolerable and
god knows what it was like for uh for
for blacks
uh and i was i was there in mississippi
delta and and covered it for
nearly seven years and i had my snoop
full of it and i left and i'll never
forget driving to washington
uh as we passed into memphis leaving
mississippi i said free at last free at
last thank god almighty free at last
and now i'm back there and back there
and very very happy because it's so much
better uh
where they really beat me back willie's
book was also very influential to me i
read that when i was still living in
clarksdale and it i really related
to it and willie became a dear friend
and uh
willie encouraged me to write a book
called dixie that is uh
kind of a reverse north toward home it's
about leaving and
going back to the south because i had
seen the transformation that had gone on
in our region and
i found i was comfortable
with with the south again and i love
being back there you know david
halperstein another dear dear friend of
mine david
started his career in mississippi
and of course uh didn't last but a year
came here to the tennessean
and uh you know the rest is history but
david had an affinity with mississippi
until the day he died he
uh spent a great deal of time in
mississippi he was our commencement
speaker
uh at ole miss uh he come down and visit
me and go to football games his
daughter worked in the mississippi delta
for teach for america and uh david's
widow just died this past summer
and uh she too as well as is after
david's death uh
the contributions go to teach for
america in the mississippi delta so uh
there are good things going on there and
uh
you know willie and and and david
they were kind of in the vanguard of
that
yes sir
my question is uh i've been a writer in
sports but the same thing where i cover
powerful people institutions and
inevitably if you say something or write
something that
makes them look less than perfect they
can try to suppress or stifle you can
you talk of an instance where
you battled with that and overcame and
were able to print what you wanted to
print how you wanted to print it
i think it helps to have a publisher
that's willing to print what you're
going to write and uh
fortunately i did for uh most of my
career
uh at the boston globe you know we we we
didn't have sacred cows and
we went after everybody and uh um
it's it's in a way it's challenging and
it's it's fun
to go after powerful institutions and
powerful people if you think that
there's something there that needs to be
revealed
but it helps to have support i mean you
really have to have the support of your
publisher or you know you're going to be
the voice in the wilderness and you're
not going to get
published so uh
you know that's just that
that's probably the most important thing
but you know i don't think one should
ever
be intimidated by these people i mean
they're human beings too they're
fallible human beings
and regardless of what kind of position
they have i think a little irreverence
helps
you know we're not paid to be
reverential
we're not paid to be
public relations officers for the people
we're covering and we're supposed to
cover them uh
and uh
whether you're covering a redneck
southern sherry for you know the
president of harvard college you know
you uh you treat them the same you know
no deference to
to anybody sure sometimes uh you'll get
cut off if it if you've got a beat for
example a sports beat you know
sports people are particularly sensitive
about uh adverse
coverage you know they're the worst you
know you can't say anything about a
coach or a player and you know they'll
try to cut you off
but uh
uh
you know i shouldn't you know i just say
you don't let that deter you just keep
on keep after it because
you know it's nothing like good honest
coverage of
things uh
whether it's sports or whether it's it's
politics
um
i have one final question and then we'll
we'll probably call it a day but in my
experience the most sensitive people
were restaurant owners i've been sued
as a publisher i've been sued more by
restaurant owners than anybody else
um what do you think of media today
at print media and could you do today
what you did then
it you know
we're in a you know kind of discouraging
situation economically so we're not as
strong as we once were
um
there
it is a struggling profession if we are
a profession some people say we're not
you know we're
a craft or maybe worse than that
um
there continues to be a lot of very good
journalism going on today unfortunately
there's not as
much of it
for example
the boston globe i can speak uh best
about it when uh
when i left there in and retired in 2000
we had i believe seven overseas bureaus
uh
the new york times had bought the globe
uh they they shut them down
um the networks uh
they they have very few
overseas networks today
i mean you'll see a
a story maybe from berlin and
and the guy who is covering it is
is in london you know he's kind of their
european
correspondent so it's not just
newspapers it's
it's everybody and and we're hurt by uh
by economics
they're still trying to come to grips
with uh
with the internet uh thank god i left
before all that yet i i i can barely do
an email i
i don't do facebook and tweets and
twitters and i i don't understand what's
going on in journalism today but
there is still
some damn good journalism going on i
read it i read six or seven papers a day
and i see good stories uh
um
they're good magazine stories there's
good television good radio for that
matter in pr
um so
it it
it's a struggle but uh you know there
are so many people who are still
interested in doing it
at ole miss
when i when we were much smaller school
when i was there but
when i was
getting a journalism major
probably no more than 20 of us
we now have about a thousand majors
and some of them
are in marketing but uh
you know more than half of them are
people who are interested in journalism
i've always said you know
it's it's the greatest kind of
profession in the world i mean it beats
working uh i mean
i mean you can't have more fun than uh
to be a journalist and be a kid from
mississippi and
you know
get to ride around as a reporter on air
force one or to
be able to live and work in the middle
east to uh
to get to cover important events uh it
is uh it's it's incredibly gratifying i
wouldn't trade it for anything i know
and sit at the outset i would of all the
stories
uh the civil rights movement's one that
was most valuable to me and that was one
i covered for a little
daily paper in
in the mississippi delta
it's a
it is a magnificent profession you know
i think
it will
we'll always be there would be kind of
like the end of grapes of wrath you know
we're the people you know we're going to
keep on coming i think i think we will
but you know we it's a tough time right
now yeah
ladies and gentlemen curtis wilkie and
thank you all very much thank you all
that's great
amen i remember
okay